Only of course.
Oh yeah
and Annabella Annabel it was it was an undertaker no Sydney used to come into the park with the usual briefcase to help
this unlabeled bottles liquid and landed saying come on in and below do you what do you drink
and you really look twenty five years of age for the last thirty years what what's the secret
but he got monkey glands or something and Bill said Would you believe in banning fluid.
If you take a year the bottle after the great crisis never swig and it was pure alcohol and I could drink it and
but anyway and everyone smashed and bombing fluid.
It keeps your loss and young and he did look only twenty four of these and he was least thirty five.
But they said Always when you die make a right to have your body powers
and I'll do you have a noise in the coffin with a little bit a root in lipstick all at night
and what happened to Annabel any questions. Just a minute on just a few years. I spent twenty years in jail.
He was a cracksman what. A psychotic. Is he still lives. This many tile on the side cracking Saint Hill.
That was over twenty five year and chose to run the parties in the train coming at an hour to be like a welcome home.
And give me enough kick off money. Nearly all through information passed through good friends in the place.
That was a homosexual. Well it is it's a privilege but it was just. What are a lot of Fandor back. These so-called.
Smoking Rand talking at Sarge they met with guns and bills. And listen to the what I call the. The graduate scenes of.
Course one of the when I don't under the weight loss in the twenty's but it was just the.
Syndrome of going to boys and wrong as they were after through a dozen The sale warnings and bone.
They get ripe for the older boys separately in the to do in their religion.
And then as they graduate through it by consoles do the right thing of the younger boy is coming when there's.
Fifteen year olds. Then they graduate to the job as it goes on and on and on that it's a vicious circle.
It's been going on for years. This is a little comes you'll find if.
The truth is now known that a good percentage of the community able some institution rather this is where they first
kick us but it's a definite syndrome that the older boys will stay in the over the younger boys right.
And then in turn that will become a homosexual except the smallest will be coming on the sexual boys bar
and that is the truth of the matter. It's only twenty's. If there's spirits. You can restrict the water. Which was a.
Very tricky tricky.
Here I think was forty three just after just after three years it was just because of the release wording of them
but you're forty four forty four forty four at the buy in the UK and homosexuals
but if I can tell you I had no idea if you got convicted for anything dealing with the old stuff you'd be locked in a
locked up. Single SILs course that be half start.
That be on the lowest possible Russian because they want contributed to the workings of. Number three ration.
They really had no tobacco. No amenities no movies. There was nothing.
The screws used to spit on them all sorts of filthy nine.
And the funny part of that was some of the graduates were rude boys and folks in their day who would spit on them.
Hasn't been a.
Chronicle but they'd be quite a few hundred journos as the commission couldn't take it any longer for home safely.
When it was horrific. It was a rigorous. They were treated worse than.
Littleton when when they lay out their lead like putting in cages in a special section.
They could have a couple of years excess or cheering the day that.
It was the usual procedure is tearing the blankets up and pay them selves off the bus. I know personally or six.
That we are here so I knew six to turn themselves in their.
And one thing that I knew they were in the special special section the season. After.
Today Wednesday at No it was meant to say there is a lot of jobs night
and that are now lighter to come in the Hennessy actually very much a day into the cages and then.
Round about half past two years I've been matched back again a lot of course in there's an area
or something for lunch and I'd be out of this bed for yesterday. There's all this and out our security interests.
It's not in practice that it's.
And then of course you'd have a couple of drunken screws that are coming on the not shift the phone to hear the call
and scream. Take a couple of they might into one of the cells and put the battens on.
The usual place with the famous ones the team and the famous
and I built the shit out of them do these them spring which is the course it doesn't happen then.
But though they were very few
and far between the tourists the rest of the warders old aside they were just local wind up little toys they unlock
that they unlocked and locked the lot. He just moved around a lot.
To robots but just had a few that were very sadistically cloned.
Coarseness starvation rush it was and there was not much of anything. It was really tough.
It was color television or they couldn't have gotten my eight and the burning places down and writing all that down.
They've never seen it better. Cause. The right Stilton to use it as it is as before.
Just one of those things that thing yesterday it's just that they pick on the weak anyone that's what exists there they
face. During these. Now an hour into very I had no sexual convictions never of course update a couple.
Of boat a couple a night.
Around here long case of course I was not good for you know never NOT NOT NEVER billion dollars net effect the talk.
If. There was one.
There was well there was a point party up
but there was the Who the are it's all small hole just at the mall like guess works pretty hard to get to secure a hole
in the past so I wanted to know who and what I say it was a reunion party faintly dis.
None of you know why that is but after midnight through the origin I see all the horror jinx going on that side.
Never again you can't get the whole. Anyone more one morning.
I was woken up with another person A on the rubbish A but the back of the whole world amongst the big captains.
Rude like that get it all never live a day. But these things went on. It was all a lot of high jinks involved in.
High Jinks and he. As US it all into. Went to Mardi Gras ball and didn't know anyone there was a brassy.
For them didn't know each other a blow out of the same somebody.
Different So you know to get those of a small parties very intimate everyone knew each other.
Skinny little flu of course. Cos there was a few tourists one of Victoria Lister.
She was the one that picked on the Hollywood. All tennis courts all and got forty pieces of forty Pam forty places.
And got a hate crime stoppers as a result. The others then you had the maximally and Barry and his name was next month.
Placements. The Berry wasn't is not all that he uses socially with a. Charity.
Business and with the use of Della spokes he was the governor of a tourism body to open the ball
and in drag went over Nevada intraday its course. So delicate was completely.
If what was going on but Barry had the newspaper there to take photographs he wrote a story to set up the the.
The truth for a story.
He also got fifty pairs I think for that
but it was that it was a set of course to bed pennies to exist in all societies. Makes.
Eventually was found on the waterfront in Melbourne with an overdose of drugs that had been pretty well known for a
number of years before that he was a police and foreman had been a place informer since he's been doing.
Very few bad pretties is the next step and a big one. And the Tories for giving pay for the first time. Know terrible.
I'm at this doors are the rest of the drunk in the cells in Sydney
and this guy from West just flies not in your Else soldiers national service.
He was lucky to skate as I pleased with it and pretty straight was nice to me
and what's what's the he tell me he'd been caught in their room at the Y.M.C.A. With another fellow.
Especially the door in and found them in big dick. So he said I don't know what to do a month forty pain and bile.
So just in the.
Salvation Army colonel was would be for the last the course Salvation Army guy
and putting the human here Rice in to be filed.
He was so lonely out of foreign take payments for being drunk and disorderly and. Lonely Hello.
Some minutes after the loose elevation followed by all the. Yeah I was. He put up to pay on the phone.
So it could be at the time and. The civil let's hit are still ongoing.
Whenever she oh she was going with you if you cannot come with us. We go.
And we went there they are and we had a swim and. That was it but taking detail.
I thought was arrested as it did when he went to the front the other.
The place that got him in the room and said Do you use for those running the guy parties in Sydney
and what did you do at least place and food and he read three states.
He done this are done that then are done this
and they are done that are done this he done that for is if it passes all lawyers. So anyway at court. This.
Turned out that he'd been convicted on the other night only to be gone before that he'd been involved with another
soldier over and wished there and my barrister tore him to pieces. This time and it read any conviction whatsoever.
And that was it enough for their eternal rhetoric or surprised. If you look with the ugly ending to this so.
You know for would all be done to the incredibly moving up to ten to fifteen years.
Its use of the hippie charges but it was fifty's. When Carney could have at last for. Usually though getting foggy.
And it was only a one to one of his nation's says this this this morning of one of mature. Course not. Children.
One to One accusations not to miss. You got to have cooperation. With children. It's a different matter.
A record on the list and if they were if the children arraigned about not only twenty.
But up here there was recently there was a the only answer he was given Father six he isn't sure he was associated with
placement and were a bit two hundred boys but certainly were brought to court to testify and one of them was twenty
when he's of age and this went back to form for three years what they've done at this announced is flat.
It's permissible in Queensland that it went to one accusation of course it wasn't one
when there was thirty witnesses and the main got six years with boys only I just seventeen. But what happened.
They remember things that went back for this means that anyone pretty two
or twenty three years of age can accuse something or somebody or something happened when they were fourteen
or fifteen or still. Just as they were not dating. You know as you know is quite true as it is.
Now by the time we left the eleven o'clock approaches shop. It was all terrible laws that. This evening work.
And I said. That. But in the court in the quarter's. Of course we had a we had a unit in a circle meeting before this.
All a our. Course we had. Were hits and that we had to list this year.
When we don't to be accused of a one dollar eighty.
He finished on up in the legal profession
and which would have to be something done because one of their members is in grave danger.
Now with the jury was in pain old lady they all cluck little guy. People today because they've in the jurymen war.
This is I'm telling you this is in the fifty's early fifty's for his visit formerly jury Borja I brought canary yellow
socks. This was unheard of. Anyone wearing their seat colors as that is the children the straightest tandem.
And one our fellow city wasn't he couldn't swear on the Bob of course he he followed his religion blues the Qur'an and.
And Marbury still we had to cross like then. Challenging because.
Beliefs is a little bit of this sort of business is permissible in the brain.
I don't know what it is but something a bear. Anyway it's not permissible in its.
But in the mother's Odenton challenging to cross a. Course when the jurors and.
The judge really summing up the summing up present only a matter of a couple of minutes.
He didn't drive on all day he just said once it is the end we're the ones who didn't use a jury you decide to sack
order for your narrow car and bring in a verdict because he was holding the gun at the head.
If you don't consider a verdict of four o'clock a lock you up will not. Which wasn't. It was not open.
There was an episode left there for straight away. If those fourteen guilty is not put.
It was a complete limited lodging. Today with the jury. But anyway there's only at the top not to have a cigarette and.
You'll get it was it right out of the hotel quick
or double brained that terrible things that they even got trim on mother's window.
And removed a large crane promote his medical cabinet and that is what they may never tence in the court.
They said I'll use this claim for a messy job on that but it was all laws that tell you.
This is a cost message powers we never heard of. Secret. Yesterday and refer send me an email.
Yes in Millburn that was another town. But that was another questionable business to. Those on.
On a war for sweating for a wedding for a bike to get across to chaos from Stony Point and three runaways he was on
and we'd mash missed the boat. So as a ten day out.
I went to like all shop and lonely Olive is now friendly he was the head.
Whiter the old MY FAVORITE to look the crusts and main course he said you Mr Barrett over to chaos.
He said Little do we solve the fish in battle tech across most of my.
Part of us he was ten dollars a cross so of the three the three layouts they got on the boat coming I got us the runner
like there was never going to rub weekend as that. Didn't. So many Why.
Oh and we interviewed for the job of a day and a fourth or fifth sixth or and. I got the job.
Nice Going To Bed Stuy than are you go over the next day to pick me gear up from. And.
The three in the War Stories going to this is well I had a boss in place. Give me a sheriff. If you could they stuck.
They couldn't get to the other side of the on the something or some story. But even if you got the others.
You got the other side in order to piss off us it was to man or this use of it will.
Reset and they shot through and the next not a lot of the Organon with. I was there. Sheriff hotel.
And a knock at the door crime and. Those three left again the gang of four gang around after them.
Because they stayed in the next not the shade three three in the sign and. Then I shut us out of this is not good.
They using me so pissed them off the next morning and three days later they get called Crikey to some place
and they are all under. The place he said and all sorts of dirty she says. Because all laws. And we should draw.
Jury was there. Three minutes. It was not.
That it was ridiculous to say they had to blame somebody else would do they were just runaways not going to rub it in
on the rain care. The others the lock. We had to get from Stanley point to gold. The fellow in the. Tail of.
The other put to show us. I just died because the jury was.
I tell you I've never been convicted of anything close to one quarter not person not. More finished. But.
It's only a matter of just. Goes back and. Courts date it anymore. Chris. All year old.
Rob is this is this is formalised warm up he. Was it was a nasty bit. As a matter of fact Paul tell you it.
Come on from the bank stand trucks out of it. Six to seven hundred on me. And. Called into. A spot up at the cross.
There was two there. But not a twenty.
Well dressed to do look at the ragamuffin top in the rough face down to mark places I got there the best was on.
Broke three ribs. Very greasy in exploring a ring up Paul and Paul come over and cooking or broke three broken ribs.
And after the release of the buses could be murder. E. OK this is these people getting murdered around the question.
And it was only a couple of months before that a white are coming in from a lighter up he was stabbed in one of the
Straights just stuff it is now the other fellows do. You know them or six would kill you. Leaving the bottoms up. And.
The funny part of day at the funny part of Bear was. When. They used to murder.
They move the school to the kids just just dinner and late seven you.
There's a skill to a chair and down there was the great council. When I was very very drunk when not very drunk and.
I was coming through the wall and dollars.
And this young fellow approach me a city's Come on smile more posturings thirty. And I was very upset.
Are you bitter or sad now it's you know there are so many yes. Good boy.
So he went he was only there for a bit for us and see these photos in the pipe
when those two guys got arrested for murder of the schoolteacher in the it was in Oregon.
So it was very lucky that the two were coursework literally because it looked very much.
I'm almost sure it was easy because when I had a year out.
You can start by course it was so close together the sequence is you know. I was a lot pleased with them. And.
That finished. But lately there's actually taking a lot in there.
Ainslie because what I can say about and for more of it. That those who operating a ramble worn around the frame.
To cross a mostly western suburbs. Stinky's.
They're not tall they only upper right to get enough to supplement the dull. Half of the wrong.
Parallel and then just to get a fix in a Subsequently if they can bash
or murder anything up to that that that is the position they are
but they call it the year the prostitution outs not so much as it's what most of its role.
In case murder comes into it. There's no way compulsion. Spurious.
Now holds but there is no guy involved in that at all. Bodies to anyone. And. These days would be here.
I think one professor said there was.
A new a twelve day the robber writing this and they still operate and there are people so they were.
Well first start you've got the. This is this is the terrible because for the scale of it. So you don't know.
Now to pick a box.
If anyone wants to even they even if anyone gets infect your way she lives or anybody else
and all the all the gods go today and there's no. I don't think.
If you read a couple of if you've had a cigarette all of you leave your full whiskey or something.
Louis or you forget the consequences. Anything while the jollies are off but forget all these and this is mine.
As well. Of they had. In the early times it was a small joie de vivre a he. Hygiene kits. There was love.
So the every part of course there was a brawl. But no one really got hurt.
There was the secrecy of it you know a lot of people leading.
So-called plain distantly the way beyond the on curtain to some matter the why whole the Nostra ring your own there's
wine and it was. Silly and you know it can do all. This is much to the rowing Norton. That. You can everyone was.
No hold by sort of this narrow Of course you have the Goldens.
They try to make at gays very polite and broom ain't take it all that.
It's really Bronte in the meeting some tall dark handsome mane at the truth and pieces insatiably good looking.
Their eyes neat and and all that it existed in my regular.
Regulator I think it is be that fourth person in almost fifty is that.
That of click to get a lock in the study
but I can say this is catch as catch can see them are unknown to the next well. That's as much as of course.
Of course there is people and that was really year very guy in the early days the original got married settle down
and went their own but it was a lira. It was.
Just after the War of the excitement all that was gone and and this was a new movement before.
When it got published in newspapers that they wish they could build a bridge week with interest as women
and lesbians and all this or that they came out of the woodwork to come out in droves.
Where's it on who's running it where we're going to get invitation that the morning or Friday night you didn't but I.
Where's it playing Hill. You'll know said the lawyer. This is to forestall any pre-arranged race but those guys.
Although it was save me. Illegal. Sammy.
There was one recall that someone else when it was only a small beer
and it was it was billed as a faith address that that is the place of often told everyone to go.
That's all they could do it was no. Although they put a little on.
Bringing non-licensed would bring Europe they were drinking on and losses.
That's as bad as much as it does it's better to cross over this was the excitement but.
This is where you didn't know where the parties were going on these that it was all the undercover. It was so much and.
The place and they'd arrest them. Once they knew if you work so. And I knew dozens that got sect.
Doesn't it was part of the year of the came time to. To find it where you were. And then bring the here.
The busts course it's because of the terrible scandal course the famous aside what never come from our part of the
family was wrong was.
Close and if you took a bit homosexuality it was beyond lot those in that pool Windisch it's Ned look at it.
From a second a cup or to the right. There for trying to get it on. You wanted to the office.
We think you could do better on. And something on that line.
I know that ultimately it will because you usually the guy personally.
Actually put in an extra little bit specially whiter.
You know you do your work will show that there was ineptitude for that school. And. With playful and.
Return making your position. There wouldn't they wouldn't they give.
If you will we don't have to give unease just a little through it but there was a terrible person.
There was one time when I refused to give me name.
Then of course after only known running the parties it got a out it was almost the top of course they even said stage
personnel these and. Other people society they want to do with these. Places when he was running them and do not.
It was all a mistreat was a new cult.
It was a subculture the people never heard of it put occasionally someone wristed in Greg and they define for paint
and that does appear in the paper the course of that work they got sector made plea. But.
It was so secret net basis than. We were the law was the the the Bengals ate and rode to bed. And carried across.
And they are think this history should be coming. Before finishing I want to tell you a bad dying death.
Dein death hated religion. In all forms Mellor United. So damn death was given to Britain years and now.
This is long before the seven leaps forward.
This new business and and dressing is in the end sitting on some rich cathedral with a bottle of wine.
And spiking alert. At a bit eight o'clock in the morning when all the people coming to work in the trains. Then.
He'd run screaming through the park
and just as the men's toilets was overrun through the men's toilets Station three me. Who want fix something.
But this was these way of getting back at the church. We just pulled it. All it's it's very strange.
I look at it all back and I think there's some sort of weather to it. It's a curse and but.
It's very very true name all of them nearly all of them all God boy some tragedy.
Was I think of these forty monk because he didn't look pretty monkey face you know those that go by and months
or a daughter Bella. Course even. When he died it was like seventy's but nearly all those the deaths of veins.
It was one of the Al canes of the time had it cut they up on the. Police on you got thrown under a train.
I mean that sort of not club in Oxford Street. It was a young young Australian.
So you know running from the scene as the story with the police on your felon in that.
Story when he was on with a young bit of a metal mind but anyway.
Then there was very for he could do killed in a fight down a little ZA restaurant that was lighted as a den of iniquity.
It was heaven. Given was one of the old gang he he was going to a job up in Queensland and the.
The loop speed of the off the top bunk and the door handle courting under the nose and the male tore off his face off.
He he was getting a large amount of compensation and then
when it came with a visit a friend got knocked down he had a camera.
There is a kind of suicides one hundred one hundred of them who committed suicide on the first fight ship was having a
favorite one of the thirty min and never will. Bethen to the pills.
There was Gloria Jane glory jury was having an affair with the captain
and someone of Titan kept North Korea in glory went to a party threaten to commit suicide with a glass of something
unless it oh yes it was threatening to kill. You you got laid low regard gone and drank it was stricken.
And we went out and have a gypsy funeral on top of the grave not he was buried.
And you know where the leaves are Randall here in the gramophone on the grave and we danced on the grave
and all that sort of business and drink plunk that was a gypsy for in funeral for the Gloria Robert's.
Got arrested for drunk and kept him in the filthy hit. Doing Jackson's day from Sydney hospital he had dropsy.
And it kept him for four days or something every long weekend and they wouldn't taking careens injections
and he died when he got along by. With the prejudicial fools that very few of them thought and next four days.
It just seems to be one of those this is where I can make a list. You know. And we go back to his.
He's recently does this fella could kick to death for six of them in Melbourne
and they they they broke the dam to Maine school.
Their Six them at three o'clock in the morning to go and put a basin
and keep them a gate at this if that isn't murder what is coming.
In there was to go in and pay to come from a guy that he got kicked to death by three of them.
Started right through the neighbors that makes the berry.
Calls that he's getting around the middle of an underworld it was an informant.
It was too many too many instances of too coincidence. And he was framed. For drugs for his it wasn't an accident and.
It goes on and on and on. Stella telefilm over mainly their low interest up in the red S. and Committed suicide.
Charlotte committed suicide. PRETORIA West and. Roberta was on the ships that was in the photographs the truth.
Roberta to take Lana to tech. Lab derisive was that it was race horses running upstate is.
All I'm saying to beef you know they're going to do boots on sort of business.